okay today's topic Andrew Tate
apparently has a tumor in his trachea
his bronchi in his lungs God damn leaked
medical documents reveal that Andrew
Tate and December made a medical visit
to hospital in Dubai then took x-ray
chest chest x-rays in December 1st on
December 12th Andrew Tate returned to
the hospital for a chess CT scan
following some medical investigations
and several anomalies were identified in
the British Man's Chest the document
also shows the presence of a hematoma in
the lung being a suspicious finding for
a more aggressive neoplastic lesion a
carcinoid tumor calcified metastases it
doesn't look good every time I read kid
yeah that's that's what I'm getting they
don't they don't look good it's a
medical medical uh you're probably gonna
die that's what I understood Andrew Tate
was good because whenever everything
good is like
okay buddy so do you have a blood in
your poop no you're off to go all right
we found something oh
calcified
this month Andrew Tate should have had
an emergency bronchoscopy and biopsy of
the lung lesions identified but no
procedure has occurred for all the
people who are medical people like how
am I pronouncing these words am I doing
a good you're pretty good okay that's
all make sure the conclusion of the
investigation carried out in Romania by
Andrew take shows at the British man
suffers from a tumor in the trachea
bronchi in lungs which has an unknown
and unpredictable evolution
Andrew Tate is thus recommended a CT
guided puncture to take tissue from the
tumor formation it is important to add
that any that many medical professionals
have advised that waiting six months
without this treatment can prove fatal
or irreversible now
there's a lot of things to glean from
this if this is true obviously this is a
terrible thing and then you you know I
don't wish to Define anybody I will say
however that this could be just employed
by the uh prosec the the defense team to
try to get him out early or try to get
him out on something that will make him
be able to travel for medical treatment
and so it's hard to gleam whether or not
this is true without looking at the
documents ourselves but it is
interesting piece of confirmation a lot
of folks feel some type of way about how
this whole thing is unfolded so I would
just ask you seeing all the updates and
everything going on what have been your
thoughts whenever you're detained you
still have to have a humane way of
getting treated and if you are sick
you're supposed technically suppose to
be uh treated so
I know how much they got in Pennsylvania
but at least be checked and if it's true
then take proper steps because that's
that could be fatal but if you want
someone to be prosecuted that person
needs to be healthy you want that person
to pay for what they did if they did
something they need to be healthy in
order to be able to pay the time others
they're gonna prosecute even if he dies
I'm pretty sure they're gonna try to
keep all that money that that civil for
all them Bugattis all that money that
they froze you know that goes straight
to the police and the the government if
they were successful yeah if you gain
money from criminal activity where do
you think that money goes when they
seize everything back to us okay I mean
by us I mean them I will say this
there's been a lot of different updates
as far as the whole medical thing goes
like would I allow him to go back to
Dubai for like life-saving emergency
treatment no because she's already
proven to be a flat risk of the
intercepted text messages and phone
conversations of him talking about how
they would run away to Dubai
like they traded so them getting bare on
one hand I don't think it's right that
without pressing any charges they're
able to hold him in prison indefinitely
what it appears like on the other hand
he has expressed the fact that he is a
flat wrist so there is a reason to want
to hold them one and two Abby brother
you left the UK and you chose this
justice system this is probably 40 of
the reason I moved to Romania people say
why didn't Romania and I explain my five
reasons one of them is the metoo era I
like the idea of being able to just say
to do what I want I like being free and
if you're a man living in England or
Germany or America or any of the western
world right now you've decided to live
in a country where any woman any ex any
[__] [__] who works at Greg's who
bought a pasty from at some point in the
future can destroy your life
I'm gonna walk in here
's mine I'm ready I'm gonna walk
get me out of jail it's a law says
you're guilty I said get me out of jail
let's go see a lawyer to talk about the
law I have committed multiple felonies
to make this all go away you talked
about how it's a joke and now that it's
being turned on you it's not that much
funny you know you was the one talking
crazy about them loud okay you know at
some point you gotta also understand you
chose this environment so that's some
accountability that you got to hold in
terms of an L right there
um but I don't think if this is
happening in North America I would think
it's unacceptable to hold somebody for
that long without charges but that's
also why I choose to live here best
believe there's plenty places in the
world that I could live at where there's
less taxes where there's less uh you
know over say surveillance to certain
things but guess what there's also
traditionally less rights there's also
listed freedoms there's less forms of
Justice you know so every country's got
a trade-off you know people want to do
this whole thing I'm gonna go here and
fix all my problems like no you just
trade in your products for a different
set of problems and you just have to
figure out which problems you want to
deal with and which ones you don't well
right every country got its ups and
downs you know one thing else what
happened if they were trying to bribe a
few politicians to speak on their behalf
in regards to getting them free oh my
God ain't that crazy so what happened is
the prosecutors prosecutor's office
intercepted some wire caps and they
ended up finding out that he was making
those costs to put pressure on those
politicians yeah to speak out so they
found those and the politicians like
we're not testing this like I would
never speak out on his behalf and so it
just starts to look worse when you see
how he's trying to game the system on
one hand I get it this dude really wants
to get out on the other the way he's
doing stuff is hella shady and he said
that he said that he could bribe
everybody when you said you chose that
yeah you chose that life you was
bragging about that life and you said
I'ma go there I'm gonna go there to not
do this not do that the criminal system
is this and that and that and now you're
there and the criminal system is that a
certain way you not getting what you
want you're using the other three you're
on the receiving handle which is hold up
hold up I will say this we have to be
careful not to be like oh Romania is
this is corrupt country people just talk
like like these people have no laws and
anything like that like they can just be
bought and you find out actually no
these people do have certain values now
you might not believe that you might say
it is absolute corruption and you're
entitled to your opinion but what the
people over there feel like is like no
this is how we do it over here this is
our form of Justice they do this things
like it's not the first time this
prosecutor has gone after crime figures
or people who run organizations so
people who are not from there are just
looking at the judicial system roaming
on a corruption Eastern Europe right
even though it really borders on Western
Europe to some degree corruption right
away it's like it's a bit also
disrespectful and a poor way to speak
about a country that you know nothing
about to just say anything that is in
the west is inherently corrupt the only
reason that they're doing this is for
money you know it's like what bro the
way I've seen those countries Slavic
countries and you know Romania and
whatever whatever okay he's turning
around Europe
I feel like every country in the world
has their form of corruption sure even
here in America whatever it's just that
they are more upfront with their [__]
but I think the level is the same thing
is that I think that there's corruption
here
in Canada in in in the states sure we
don't they're not that open about it
they're really good at making it look
like they're not about that life when
they're about that life when people are
making deals it's always 10 20 30 years
later that you figure out something on a
Netflix special of the corruption that
happened before so they sin as much as
we sin it's just they just do it
differently and it's kind of maybe more
open can't talk a lot about a country
that you're not from but you're not from
like you own the [__] I can't go to
Cuba and talk [__] about Cuba they gonna
X me you understand what I'm saying I
mean you can't go to a country and then
talk a whole bunch of [__] and be open
about it doing podcasts and you [__] on
that country and the minute that they
got something on you you think they're
not gonna do something yeah it's like if
I go to your house and I talk [__] about
your house if you found that find out
you gonna ask me to leave or you're
gonna you're gonna do something my house
might not be the best house but you're
certainly not gonna come inside and
start talking crazy they already have
enough motivation to come after you for
criminal activity then they find out you
think their justice system is a joke
at the justice system yeah we're gonna
go to Singapore and spit on the ground
and call this [__] they're going to [__]
you up yeah and I won't feel bad maybe
it's not the right thing but I certainly
won't feel bad for you you kind of asked
for it I'll say this I think as
everything has been coming out people
have been like oh this is bogus oh this
is more real I remember at one point
there was a text conversation between
two of the victims and people said that
[__] was fake look they're making false
allegations then the full context of the
conversation comes out and then it turns
out it makes Andrew Tate look worse than
what it originally was basically it was
chopped and screwed so everybody gonna
pick and choose where they're at I stand
on this side from what I've seen of
minimal evidence it to me it appears
like he's guilty but I would does it it
doesn't really matter because at the end
of the day it has to go to court and it
should be put in front of the judicial
system to be handled but to act like
there's no cases crazy to me that's what
I personally think anything else you
want to ask oh man you think you think
you got cancer
it's a possibility like
cancer is out there you know I mean even
me
I don't even I don't even say if I get
cancer I say when really you your
convention gonna get it bro my
grandfather died of prostate cancer my
dad had brain cancer my mom had breast
cancer I got wonderful genes for my
facial features for my for the cancer
not so great the jeans okay so it is
somebody lied to you about the facial
feet the face maybe they did but it is
besides the point the point is
[__] my G's are not good for
cancer if they're not good for my face
they're not good for they certainly not
good for cancer I'm gonna tell you that
you know what I mean just [__] around I
know you're [__] around that's why I
don't pay attention that's good
everyone's like no I have but your face
is ugly I'm like that's okay guys thank
you I appreciate you yeah
yeah
you just I got this and then like what
about your dad I'm like oh yeah he got
it too you gotta check you just gotta
don't win that [__] you just gotta check
it early and it's just a message from my
this is a whole lot of topic I know all
my Haitian people and my Caribbean
people talk to your kids about how
people die don't be afraid because that
helps us in the future go check your
blood pressure Jesus [__] Christ go
check your blood pressure anyways I'm
just saying that food I love it but that
ackee and saltfish
it's very salty yo okay go take your
blood pressure other than that I think
that's pretty much all I really have I
don't know uh there's a lot of updates
and people ask us why we don't cover it
it feels like there's always new thing
happening but I thought this one was
pretty big in regards to the cancer
because I think it's a very different
angle on this whole thing I mean if you
got cancer I'm sure there's plenty
people will be celebrating like oh yeah
[__] you misogyny go kill all right I
know other people will be like damn The
Matrix The Matrix gave him cancer
okay okay
all I'm saying is if he does I hope he
gets treatment in Romania as he should
not going to Dubai to get a free ride to
be able to run away from these charges
but yeah outside of that I think that's
pretty much it in Romania because it's
not good enough for you well then you
shouldn't be talking [__] and you
shouldn't be in Romania you shouldn't be
talking [__] you chose that country let
us know what you guys think in the
comments below